hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to reality
check the show about science games Tech
and all the middleware in between the
technology may have been around for
decades but it was one Kickstarter just
three short years ago that support
virtual reality to the forefront of
everyone's minds and heads it didn't
take long for the idea to get funded ten
times over and soon prototypes of a new
piece of affordable cutting-edge tech
started to surface we know it as the
oculus rift in just three years the
virtual reality playing field has
changed other players have stepped into
the ring Sony Microsoft Google valve and
even today's sponsor Samsung for oculus
for cool two billion dollars and next
year consumer versions of the rift the
HTC vive and the PlayStation VR are
hitting the market so what better time
to do an episode all about how virtual
reality works virtual reality is
basically a big trick well a few little
tricks working together the hardware
aims to deceive your brain into thinking
that your body is in a completely
different place and a key part of making
it work is the concept of presence or
the extent to which you feel like you're
in the virtual environment rather than
your immediate physical one think about
it this way if you're seeing a 3d movie
in the cinema say Star Wars you're
immersed in the experience just as long
as you're looking at the screen move
your head to the side and bam you
suddenly remember that you're not on the
planet of tatooine and instead you're in
the local sinner worlds so in order to
keep you immersed in the experience the
trick starts by blocking out your actual
surroundings hence that big headset and
power head
inside the head set of two screens with
a field of view of 110 degrees meaning
that there's no edge of the movie screen
effect in your peripheral vision each
screen displays a slightly different
image for each eye this is a trick
called stereoscopy try it now
focus on an object now close your left
eye open it and close your right
notice how the object moves to the side
ever so slightly well with both eyes
open your clever brain merges the two
inputs to create one image in VR to
slightly offset images are shown to your
eyes and the brain does the rest so
you're in the virtual world but where
well this is where the tracking
technology comes into play if you move
your head and the image on the display
doesn't change in 50 milliseconds max
you're gonna start feeling sick so the
information is quickly pieced together
from various sources like a gyroscope an
accelerometer that measures how fast
you're going and a magnetometer to
correct drift most headsets are covered
in tiny LEDs whose signals are then
picked up by a nearby camera from this
the precise location of your headset and
therefore your location within the
virtual space is calculated so you can
start moving around and exploring if the
technology has been around for so long
why hasn't VR been more widely available
well cost is one reason the other is a
possible side effect cyber sickness and
I'm speaking from experience here
because the early versions of the oculus
rift made me sick as a motion sick prone
dog scientists believe that the nausea
that some people feel after using
virtual reality headsets stems from a
mismatch in sensory information if
you're zipping around within your VR
world but you're actually sat down in
real life your body and your brain
particularly the input it gets from the
inner ear that's responsible for balance
aren't in sync and that's when the
queasiness starts take dying light for
example a first-person game where you
play a zombie killing parkour artist
it was rift enabled but jumping over
zombies and clambering up and down
buildings is a lot trickier to stomach
when your brain knows that you're
actually just sat in a chair holding a
gamepad so ya do not recommend it
on the older versions of VR headsets
luckily the cyber sickness problem has
been at the forefront of developers
Minds valve for example have claimed to
eradicate it completely
there's no sensory mismatch with your
movement because their lighthouse
tracking system allows users to walk
around in a 5x5 meter space both in real
life and within the virtual environment
and despite it being the easiest way to
interact with the game nothing kicks you
out of the immersion faster like having
to use a keyboard a mouse or a gamepad
instead of your hands that's why the
PlayStation VR oculus rift and vive will
all support trackable controllers that
allow you to interact with the virtual
world if you want to reach out and touch
something move something or interact
with something you can just reach out
and do that the more you can trick your
brain into buying into the system the
better the VR experience will be and
luckily that's where we're at now so
that's a brief look at how virtual
reality works for more on the topic
check out this week's episode of the
gist we're just real soft so the most
exciting VR games around and ones that
are just on the horizon or take a look
at in two minutes where I talk about the
future of VR gear VR Google cardboard
and the oneplus are all available now
with the vive PlayStation VR and of
course the oculus rift launching in 2016
which is incidentally the next time I'll
see you as I'm away for the next couple
of weeks but don't worry I've left you
in the care of Kate and Dave from the
pull up or show in the meantime I'll be
on Twitter at Lucy James games have a
great break whatever it is you're doing
and I'll see you in 2016